hoy nate tiene 100 plátanos él va a
comer dos de ellos cada día el número de
plátanos que nate deja es proporcional
al número de días transcurridos
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de responder esto por su cuenta
lo interesante aquí es que nos preguntan
el número de plátanos que nate deja no
los que ha comido si este número es
proporcional al número de días
transcurridos vamos a dibujar una tabla
aquí
va a tener tres columnas
en la primera columna vamos a poner el
número de días transcurridos
qué es esto de aquí
en la columna del medio pondremos el
número de plátanos que nate ha dejado el
número de plátanos que nate deja y en la
última columna vamos a escribir la
proporción entre estos dos números y
para que esto sea proporcional la razón
de entre estos dos números debe ser
igual así que son plátanos dejados o el
número de plátanos que faltan por comer
entre el número de días que han
transcurrido
plátanos que deja dividido entre el
número de días transcurridos pensemos un
poco en esto cuando ha pasado un día
cuántos plátanos quedan en el día 1 él
ha comido dos plátanos por lo que nos
quedan 98 plátanos cuál es la proporción
de los plátanos que quedan entre los
días transcurridos pues 98 entre 1 que
es igual a 98 cuando han pasado dos días
cuántos plátanos quedan pues se habrá
comido dos plátanos más por lo que
quedan 96 la proporción aquí van a ser
96 entre 2
que es igual a 48 claramente esta razón
no es constante ha cambiado con pasar de
un día al siguiente no tenemos una razón
constante entre el número de plátanos
que deja y el número de días que pasan o
que transcurren así que esta no es una
relación proporcional no es relación
proporcional la cosa pudo haber sido
diferente si nos hubieran preguntado el
número de plátanos que nate se come cada
día esto será proporcional al número de
días que transcurren pues claro que sí
porque aquí si estos son los plátanos
comidos siempre será 2 por el número de
días transcurridos aquí serán 2 aquí
serán 4
y estas proporciones o razones siempre
serán igualados
pero esto no es lo que nos preguntan
aquí nos piden comparar el número de
plátanos que deja con el número de días
transcurridos